Good Morning Believe Nation, Today, we're going to talk about how to choose the right career.
You have to love what you do and I'm not going to go.
Over that long but it solves a lot of problems
Because when you love what you do Would you really love what you do you Work Harder [i] mean I have friends that don't love
And you know I tell this Story a wall Street-Type
Big Guy
But I was Richer Than Him and I'm Richer According to forbes of much richer [than], him so i like that you know I
Like that but There's big
Wall Street Titan he's A. Big Name he has a son and his son is a wonderful [human] being Which Is
Amazing Because The Guy's a Horrible a, horrible Person
But he's one of the biggest Guys on wall Street
So he wants his son Alex I'm gonna use the Name Alex it's not his Name but
I don't want to get This Guy in Any more trouble with his Father the new Already it's
Alex isn't the Strongest Character the father is a brutal Vicious Killer
so
The Father Has A big Firm, on wall Street and he Wants Alex to go
Into The Firm of Course you know Come on Alex Get in There Get in There in The Meantime all these Kids are Graduating from
Wharton and Harvard and Stanford and They're Just Eating Alex's lunch he
Doesn't Have a chance he does have a chance and he doesn't like it he's not
Liking what He's doing you got to love what you, do he's not like him
So one day but he Can't leave Because There's Father I actually told why
Don't you leave your father's Brutal the father's Just Killing the Guys Tell him you, don't have what it Takes
I'm sorry dad oh this is great
So i say you got to leave the father you got to leave him
He Said I just can't Donald [Sonja] he's a spoiled Guy He's a member of A very good [golf] Club in
Westchester Which is a rich place in New York and
He's on one of the Committees and he's on the Greens Committee and They put Him in Charge of Redoing the Course They're doing This
Big Renovation of the Course it's A very Good Club and
He's There Every Morning at 5:00 in the Morning
He doesn't leave he did such an
unbelievable Job
The Contract Is Respected him, everybody Respected him so the wife Comes Up he's Doing so great Donald he's so Amazing and
They Give Him an Honor and this is a Tough Group of People that have this love you know the Club Members and They're difficult
They gave Him an, Honor the Club Came in under Budget
Faster By two Months he, did an unbelievable Job and The Quality of the Work
Was ten Times What They ever Anticipated so they gave him a Medal [I] said you know
Alex you, were to go and do this for a living you
Were to be a builder whether it's Houses or Clubs or golf Courses Renovation or this
Oh my father Would go crazy at
Devil Levity so Alex went back to wall street Where he was Miserable and A year Later he Quit and
he Started Doing
Renovations of Houses and Clubs and Different Things and He's doing great so you've got to love
What you, do?
Step Number, one Is the most important part of the Process and that is Prepare your mind alright When
We get, Into ruts okay? We get Into Relationship ruts, We get Into Workout ruts?
We get, Into Career ruts when this happens, We Let Ourselves Worth and our Value Depreciate right?
We don't Feel as Confident as good as we [Should]?
Well Step Number one Is to prepare Yourself to start Feeling good about
Yourself in Order to Take Action and to Realize that you are not only a Success you are going to be an Incredibly Valuable
Commodity you need to Condition your mind and Realize that you are a valuable Asset [okay] you're not Just John from Accounting
No you're John
Yeah you might Work in Accounting now but Look out world I am Coming
But you need to realize that the job hunting Process and Finding A
New Career it's not A quick Fix alright if it was everybody be doing it okay it does Take Time and the Bigger or more
Drastic of a change that you're going to Make the longer you're Going to need to Prepare for
But One Thing that Is critical Is to Keep your mind Focus and to Keep your mind in A good space
One Thing that I would
Recommend Doing in Order to Feel good about
Yourself Something That Works for Me and I know it Works for A lot of other People is to Volunteer
Yeah it has Absolutely Nothing to do With your new Career
But it has to do With you Feeling good about Yourself
This is also a great Time to up your Image at your Style your Grooming Game alright What happens After You get a haircut
Exactly Feel Great what happens when you get a new pair of Shoes yes
You're Like Whatever Check out my Shoes I feel good right this is a perfect Time to take Inventory of what you have
Spruce up Where you need to but all in all you're Putting Together the best personal Package that you Possibly Can from mind to Shoes
One of the ProbleMs in the World Is that you Have Two choices
Almost Always you Can, choose Status or you can
Choose Substance and he Says what happens with A lot of People when
They're Figuring out What They Should do With Their life you know they listen to let's Say your mom Says, oh being A
Doctor you know that's Such A great Job it's so prestigious You'll Always
Make Money but and so People [I] in fact my den
So I was like 15 years Old he Wanted to be an Artist he Told me but
His Mom Made him, be A dentist Because it, was a higher Status but
He Didn't have That real Feeling for it you know even That the Substance, wasn't there so Peter teal
The Uh you know
He's the Co-Founder of Paypal and
Now a billionaire he Says when you have Those choices when you have that Fork in the road?
Really go after the substantive Thing and so as you're Figuring out your general Career in your Business Destiny don't just go
okay
Everybody Now I'm not Saying you shouldn't be [a] Doctor a lot of People Should be Doctors we need more Good Doctors but don't be
A Doctor just because the Status Is There Because you
Won't have The highest Level of Curiosity?
That you need to Really Thrive in what you ever do and the first Part of This Three-Step Passionate Work
Framework is Becoming A self Expert and Understanding Yourself because if you
Don't know what you're Looking for you're Never going to find it and the thing Is that no
One's going to do this for us you know There's no Major in
University on Passion and Purpose and Career I don't know how that's not a required Double Major but don't even don't even Get
Me Started on that I mean you Spend more Time Picking out A
Dorm Room TV Set Than you do you know Picking your Major in your Area of Study
But The point Is it's on us to Figure that out and We need a framework we need A?
Way to Navigate Through this and
So the first Step of our Compass is Finding what our unique Strengths are what are the things that that, We wake up?
Loving to do no Matter what Whether Pay to or not Pay the things that People [thanked] us for and
Strengths Finder 2.0 Is a book and also an online tool
Highly Recommended for sorting out what it Is that you're Naturally good at and then next what's our what's our Framework or our?
Hierarchy From Making Decisions You know Is that the People that are
Do We care About you know the People our Family health or is it achievement [Success] all this Difference up
We have to Figure out what it is to Make These Decisions so We know what our soul Is made of?
so that We don't go selling it to some Cause, we don't give a shit about and
Then
The Next Step Is our Experiences We have?
All of Us Have These Experiences We learn Things Every Day Every Minute about what We love what?
We hate what we're Good at what we're Terrible at and?
If We don't Spend Time Paying Attention that and Assimilating that that Learning and Applying it to the rest of our life it's all for
Nothing it's like Every Week actual every Day Every Week every Month Every Year I Spend some Time Just reflecting
On what went right what Went Wrong and what do I want to Repeat?
What Can I Apply more to my life and Even More so than that as you See People Especially Today who
Inspire You who are doing things where you say, oh god what Jeff Is doing I want to be like him
Why are you Saying That Open Up a journal write Down
What it is About then that Inspires you it's not going to be everything about Their life but you Know Whatever it Is
Take Notes Over Time, We Have This Repository of Things That?
We can use to Apply to our life and Have A more Passionate Existence and Make A better Impact because When
We start To do Put These things Together?
We can then define what it is Success actually Means to Us and Without These Different Parts of the Compass it's Impossible
We end Up in the Situation We have that you know scripted life that you know Everyone Seemed to be Living going up this ladder
To Nowhere it's kind of like in Wall street to of Anyone. Saw that the
Kind of Peon Employee Asked the big Wall Street Bank
Or Ceo Said you know, what's your number, everyone's got a number what they Make this Money They leave it all
This is so
Simple More
Free Just smiles and This it's the Sad State of Most of the People that haven't Spent Time Understanding What Actually Matters then
We Keep Reaching for something that doesn't Mean Anything to us but we're Doing it because Everyone Said?
We're Supposed to but Once We have This Framework Together
We Can start to Identify that thing that Makes things that Make Us come alive you know before This
Passion Could Come and hit you in the Face Or
Maybe in your Possible Life Work you might Throw it to the side because you don't have a way of IDentifying
It but Once you
Do you can See something that's Congruent with my Strengths my values who I am as a Person
So i'm going to Grab a hold of some going to do something with it and I'm going to Pursue It and Try and try
To Make an Impact with it and
You live your legend and the Movement we've built
Wouldn't Exist if I Didn't have this Compass to Identify wow this is Something I want to Pursue and Make a Difference With
So if We don't know what
We're Looking for we're Never going to find it
If You want to know how to Decide if a Career Opportunity is a good one There are several things you have to take Into
Consideration
Number One Does it Make your heart sing the Number One Feedback System that you are given at birth Is Joy if You're not
Experiencing Joy as you as you think About doing something and as you pursue doing it then it's off Course for you you
Also want to put your rational mind to work you want it to some due Diligence [ask] other People who've gone Down that road before
What was it like what did They have to do what were some of the cost of that Path?
Well were some of the Bay Offs and the Benefits and
Really Get A sense of what it Would be like to do that
Sometimes you Can Go and do an Internship or you Can Work for A friend in Their Restaurant Just to see if you
Like it because often The Fantasy doesn't Match the Reality and the other Thing is to Simply trust
Yourself You Know
Deep inside
What's true for you [and] if You'll Take A few Minutes and go inside We Call it Meditation and Just ask and sit with the
Question and See what Kind of Feelings Come up does This Feel right so do all the
Rational Research but Then Ultimately bring it Back Into your Heart and
Decide Does this Feel good for Me and if it Makes sense Up here and it Feels good then
Step Into it just Lean Into it and see what happens Pursue it, no
Decision Is Forever you Can always change if it's not what you want?
How Should I Approach Finding a Career that is Fulfilling but doesn't Strengthen my Ego and
Secondly and Perhaps the more Pressing Question for me Is how do I do this While
Also becoming Comfortable and Embracing the Uncertainty that's Defining my life right now
Good Lesson - yes
so
To what extent have you?
Become Successful in Embracing and Accepting at this Time of your life
That You don't know yet what your Purpose Is to what extent are you able to Say well
C-Can I become Comfortable With not Knowing
Have you, been able to do that
I'm
Curious Where I've Been able to but Mostly it's just A lot of Thinking and Feeling very Uncomfortable about not Knowing
Yes so when These Thoughts Arise They tell you it's not
okay
The way you are right Now Is not okay realize that These are Thoughts That Arise in your mind
Conditioned But by the Surrounding Culture and so on and you
Don't Necessarily need To believe in each Thought it Comes and tells you it's not, okay not to know. What to do
Life IS an Adventure
It's not a packaged tour when you travel you Can Take a package tour
And everything is Already Planned There's no Uncertainty
and Every Year go to Huge nice Hotel Room the more Exotic Country but you
Won't even Know it's exotic because your tailor is the Same as every other Hotel room you're Totally Sure About [everything] is Planned you know
Beforehand Where You're Going to be in ten Days Time Exactly that's not an Advance and it's Unlikely that you are going to
Evolve Internally Through a trip like that
But if You Went Into a true
Trip Into Some Exotic Country Thrown Back on your Own Resources then you would encounter true
Adventure but all in The end you Would Probably not be the Same [Person] when you come back why not
Because, We are Constantly Faced with Uncertainty and
If You're able to Accept that you Can, actually Enjoy the Adventure if you cannot Accept it I'm Giving This
Analogy of A trip Because life is a Journey yes so realize that life IS an Adventure and Part of the Adventure of life
Is being in That State That you are in Now if Everything were Already clear to you now everything we Already Mapped out?
There Would be no evolution of Yourself and Maybe i say IV that is part of What being 26 Is all about?
that Is that Is what 26 Is you're Trying to Figure it out that Is
Yeah that Is what the 20s are for yes and and Another very
Helpful Thing To Remember Is one of the
Most Wonderful things it in your period of life is to Make Mistakes yeah because Mistakes Means you Realize
oh that's not that wasn't my Purpose yes and so you're a little bit closer to your True verbs and Then Perhaps you think
Oh Baby that Is my father's and then you after a while you realize no that's not and it's very Helpful to Make Mistakes Because
Gradually You Begin to realize what it is that
Is right for you
Thank You Guys so much [for] Watching I hope you enjoyed my quick Take on it Is I [think] There's A lot of Pressure People
put on Themselves To find the right Career and often Way too early
Whether it's Pressure You put on Yourself or pressure that other People friends Family
Society Is Putting on you and I think the worst Thing [that] you can do is get [Yourself] locked in
A career and not be able to jump off I think too many People
Do it Because it's a smart [thing] the safe thing to do and they end up living for the Weekends in the evenings
And They hate Their Jobs and that Ends Up being you know
They hate Their Lives and I don't want that to be you and I think
It Takes A Lot of Courage
To Jump Off One Path to go for something Else Especially when you don't know how it's going to Work out
But if You find Yourself Going to Work Every day and hating what you're Doing
Then You have to change you have to change
What you're up to because otherwise?
That's what you're going to do for the rest of your life and it's only Going to get Harder and Harder and Harder to Jump
Off To a Different Career Path for me it's Chasing what what
Makes Me Come alive if you have something that you're Curious About go out and Try it don't don't Make it some big
expensive Project that You Just Can't Afford to do that
Requires You to quit your Job
You know do something Small do Something on the side Just Test it out Whatever big dream you have Whatever
Curiosity You Have
Find the smallest way to get Started if You want to learn how to Dance Salsa for Whatever Reason I never imagined being an
Owner an
Investor in A salsa dancing Business
But I had an Inclination to try Salsa and I liked it and I fell in love with It and it Became a business Opportunity
For me I've Tried a whole bunch of other Stuff [that] hasn't Worked out and That's okay too?
The important Thing Is [to] start Small do Little Tests see what Makes you come alive See what Feels good
See
What Gives You energy and then Continue to find Ways to do that over and Over and over again and the Path
you Know the Staircase will Appear With, Every step, that you Take
I made this Video because Abdullah asked me to so there's a topic you'd like me to cover in the next Edition of believe life
Leave in The Comments I will See
We can do so the Question today today is I'm Curious as to how you found?
your Career
Or what Career Advice you give to other People who are Searching for it leaving [the] Comments Below I'm going to join a Discussion
Thank you so much for [Watching] Have an Amazing day Continue to believe and I'll see you soon
Here's A great Discovery only the truly Competent Individual can be free of Politics in an Organization
When you're Really good at what you do you Can, Actually rise above Politics
Think About it it's the Mediocrities at Work you have to play Games and Every Study Shows [that] Although They
Sometimes Succeed in The Short Term They Invariably Fail When Everyone Figures them out
Select your Work Carefully and if You don't love what you're doing enough to want to be the best at it get out
Flee From The Boring or Unsatisfying Job as you Would from a burning Building
Working [at] something that you, don't Care About is the very Best way [to] waste your life
Remember This life Is not a rehearsal for something Else
One key To getting Onto the fast track Is for you to Work for the right Company and the right Boss
The Right Company Is One That respects its People and Practices Pay for Performance
The Right Company is Dynamic Growing open to new Ideas and Full of Opportunities for People With
Ambition and initiative Michael gerber the Guy That wrote the E-Myth you know Talks about why so Many businesses Young businesses Fail
And One of These things he Says Is most People are not Really, Entrepreneurs but They Think that's what they Should be?
They Think That's the sexy Thing that's the most attractive Thing that's the Best answer and
What i say to you is you've Got to separate The vehicle from the Outcome?
What is it that's Going to truly Fulfill you what is it that's Going to give you that extraordinary Life what's going to Make Things
Magnificent on your Terms not Somebody Else's Terms not your father your mother your Background what is that Really?
Separate The vehicles There's Many Ways to [get] to that vehicle what I'm Saying
Sometimes You got to reevaluate What's going to really, Make you fulfill
What is your?
Gift are you an Artist are you the Talent Can Produce something
No One Else Produces as a skill or a product or a service or some Impact are you Incredibly good at management
You Really know how to Manage or lead People are you an extraordinary
Entrepreneur That Has Can Take That Gigantic gut Load of Risk and
Can Create The Vision and Tract the Talent that you need in The Managers and Leaders
You May have all Three Abilities
But Which One Really Fulfills you the most is going to be the critical Question Because?
We tend to want to do them all Especially the room like this Because?
You're all
Overachievers Right me Too and You say I can do all these yes you can but what will it do to your Quality of life
See again the secrets Going to be this what Is an extraordinary life on your terms Today?